This stuff is called a halo-halo...
...and it might just be the most satisfying dessert in the world.
Here we have all the ingredients for halo-halo,...
...which is Tagalog for "mix-mix."
It's a popular Filipino cold dessert that's not only popular,...
...it's the dessert of the country.
As Anthony Bourdain called it, "It's oddly beautiful."
I don't even know what half of these ingredients are.
It's made from shaved ice, condensed milk...
...and lots of sweet toppings like jello, corn, fresh fruit,...
...coconut, ube ice cream and leche flan, Filipino sweet custard.
So how often do you eat it?
How often?
Once a week?
No, it's thrice a week.
It's a snow cone.
It's an ice cream sundae.
It's a sugary fruit cup that is so addicting,...
...you cannot stop eating.
Halo-halo's roots come from Manila in the 1920s.
It was created as a spin-off of the Japanese dessert, "mitsumame..."
...because at the time, the Philippines was under Japanese control.
Today, every province, every city and every town in the Philippines...
...has their own version of halo-halo.
Secret sauce.
That's the secret ingredient.
Especially in the summertime when it's so hot.
I know I tend to exaggerate sometimes,...
...but halo-halo is truly one of the best desserts you can try...
...and it's only here in the Philippines.